[Music]
[Applause]
but first I want to bring in mik Mike
Florio pro football talk live co-host
and contributor to football night in
America because we saw a story back in I
think July that hinted at Caleb Williams
maybe wanting a piece of the franchise
if he whoever he's drafted by Aaron
Rogers with the Jets did he ask for a
piece of the team and I'm curious that
it got so much traction because
you can't it's not allowable but it
surfaced again and then I thought is
somebody maybe trying to sabotage Caleb
Williams now putting it out there again
so I thought let me get Mike Florio here
to help us understand this go back to
the story The Genesis of it and how we
got to this moment now with Caleb
Williams Mike let me make it as simple
as possible Dan back in July when the
League approved the sale of the
commanders to Josh Harris one of the
other items of business was to slam the
door on any Equity transfers to players
or non-players period now you don't just
make those decisions out of thin air you
do it because you're aware that some
stuff may be going on and it may be an
issue so the league preemptively says
this can't happen in the immediate
aftermath of that sources that I trust
very deeply not to be confused with the
sources I don't trust but still listen
to but sources I trust very deeply said
number one Aron Rogers had been trying
to shake a little Equity out of the
Woody Johnson tree and now that's over
and also Caleb Williams dad had been
telling prospective agents that's one of
the things he's looking for now look
does Caleb Williams dad understand how
it works no but it doesn't matter once
they slam the door on it and I think
what happened Dan was he had a bad game
Saturday night and it's a perfect
opportunity to crap on Caleb Williams so
these twitterbot accounts start dusting
off a three-month-old story to make
Caleb look unreasonable even though it's
completely irrelevant to anything that's
happening now that's it in a nutshell
okay is Caleb Williams saying there
there's only five teams that he would
want to play for is that true I saw that
I I saw that somewhere on Twitter and I
haven't seen it source to anyone look I
think Caleb Williams and his dad are in
the process of trying to understand what
leverage he has and how to go about
using it for the NFL this is like
Haley's comic it happens once every 21
years John Elway did it in 83 Eli
Manning does it in ' 04 is Caleb
Williams goingon to do it one of these
guys is going to do it because they're
either going to stay in school for
another year or have enough money in the
bank from their nil payments that they
can say if you draft me I'm sitting out
the whole year and doing it all over
again so I think they're just in the
process of figuring out what their
Leverage is and how they're willing to
use it all right thank you Mike see you
that's Mike floral pro football talk
live co-host and